tim is with us tim is in missouri hi Tim
how are you hey Dave I'm doing well how
about yourself better than I deserve
what's up well I'm currently working
through the baby steps I'm currently on
baby steps 3-pin for saving 15% of my
income for retirement and then also
saving a bunch of money for hopefully
house down payment in a upcoming wedding
in 18 months
all right trying to figure out what what
intensity as you go with because my
fiance has that and I'm saving up money
for that as well so I wasn't or should I
be doing gazelle intensity or should I
just be kind of living like maybe buying
some furniture here upgrading my car
things like that I think paying for a
wedding is more important than a car so
I don't think I feel a car until I had
the wedding done I think the day that
you get married and come home from the
honeymoon writing a check and paying off
hurler that's more important than you
upgrading a car I think you know a few
other things there so just I'm using the
car upgrade as an example of a luxurious
take it an easy kind of thing this
example you used right so yeah yeah but
I mean what I always do is stuff like
this man is I just sit down and say okay
what do I want the most it's not that I
can't get the other it's that I'm gonna
get it second or third or fourth or
fifth and so what I want most and if I'm
in your shoes I want this wedding that's
the most exciting thing in your life
right now and then oh yeah for sure
sorry I'm just more taken back you know
I mean if I'm if I'm here when I was
your age that's all I could think about
if I was getting married that's the
whole thing and you know you're it's a
financial goal to because paying for the
wedding is a big deal and so how much do
you need for the wedding um thinking
about 15,000 okay have y'all set a
budget yet uh still in the early phases
of planning but we're thinking oh
probably around 50 or 20 okay well then
you need to say I got 18 months to save
that and so if it's
18 months for 18,000 $1,000 a month
right yeah okay
and so we got to have that budget oh by
the way if you got there in nine months
you could move on to your next goal you
don't have to wait 18 months to get
there
matter of fact you can't because you're
not you have to pay for most of it
before you get there so but yeah you
need to lay out your goals or exactly
what it is and then you know what I do
say all right I'm gonna stay ghazal
until I get that done and then I'm gonna
stay ghazal until I have enough
additional savings to pay off her debt
when we get home from the honeymoon and
yeah and only then what I start talking
about buying furniture upgrading because
in a sense buying furniture upgrading is
causing her debt to hang around longer
after you're married that makes sense
yeah good yeah so I'm just prioritizing
I'm just listing what do I want first
what I want second what do I want third
and we'll get there to all the houses
down the list it's on down the list
before I save for a house in your
situation I might move up in car or I
might do some luxury things or whatever
though those are possible plays as well
so um but you know you can just kind of
list it out and say this is what we want
to do this what we want to do first this
one under second and it was a great I
remember the first time I actually
implemented that strategy folks it was
like this awakening because we had
always I think we were just being
melodramatic Hillbillies you know we
were just like everything was all or
nothing right and it's like you have to
fight like to the death because it's all
or nothing and we finally just realized
it's not no it's just which is first
it's yes to both everything on his list
is a yes the wedding the car upgrade the
house purchase paying off her debt I
increasing the quality of his lifestyle
loosening up all of those are yeses just
which yes comes first that's all it is
and it's saying no to something so I can
say yes to others you're always gonna do
that because money's always finite but
my wife was driving one of those just a
thousand years ago
you don't remember those two-tone ugly
blue Astro vans they were nasty looking
but we thought at the time they were
cool
I had like bucket seats and it was like
a minivan but it wasn't a minivan I was
like between a real van and a minivan
kind of thing and back in the day right
and the kids the key you know we had
kids so this was our gonna be our kid
hauler when we drove the wheels off that
thing and we raised several dogs and
several kids in that van and it was
nasty and it was worn completely
freaking out it was on the second
transmission the old engine was on its
last leg and you know so we're out of
debt finally we're booking along we're
doing pretty good but we still got this
nasty but old van right and I the
business was growing and I had this
particular thing I could do down here at
the business it was like $25,000 and I
was pretty sure that if I took that
25,000 and placed it there is gonna make
me a hundred pretty sure I mean it would
take a few years to get it all back but
I was it was it was a really it was an
investment it was a growth thing in the
business I just really really really
wanted to do and my wife is uh not
wanting she's really really really
really wanting to no longer drive this
ugly butt old astro van and so we get
this big argument about it it's like
well you know it's like as if we had to
do one and not the other and I remember
that fight because it was a breakthrough
and we finally just said wait a minute
we can actually do both we just need
50,000 instead of 25,000 and if we're
gonna buy twenty five thousand on a car
or do a $25,000 investment at the office
oh we need 50,000 if we're gonna do both
right and so we've got to have so where
we going so it's not a matter of never
doing one or the other it's just which
one goes first well as you might imagine
the purchase of the $25,000 suburban
which was a five-year overdue upgrade to
this car
considering all the hell my wife had
been through with me in this process and
it was a small percentage of our income
and everything else but as you might
imagine the first 25 went to her getting
this the white suburban oh that thing
was a land yacht - it was so long but
they still are they still make the same
body same same wheelbase on that thing
it's a big old freaking car anyway we
bought her her bought her that before we
moved on and did the business and then
we went ahead and did the business
upgrade as well
there's just not it wasn't no to both
it's just which one is first and that's
really Tim's dichotomy not yes or no
which one's first